Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie, Attack on Titan Season 4
Released the trailer for the final episode.
Final episodes.
They're basically jamming it into one
giant episode,
so I'll explain what's going on.
There's a bunch of new footage
and Easter eggs here.
Watch them break
like the last 5 minutes of the series
into like four separate movies that they
then release over the next five years.
but if you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe
to get all the episodes.
Of course,
I'll do a video for the actual ending
when they release it,
because it'll be like one giant episode,
kind of like a movie that they might
also try to release in theaters
and make some extra money on it.
but they will be releasing it normally
on Crunchyroll and other online platforms.
just in general,
we have a bunch of big stuff coming up.
Like the one piece is Netflix episodes.
And then next year
we'll also have the live action Avatar
The Last Airbender episodes.
Of course, we'll do videos
for those crossing our fingers on that
that it winds up looking pretty decent.
there's also a bunch of animated Avatar
The Last Airbender stuff coming up too
from Mike
and Brian on their side of things
that'll be completely separate
from the Netflix stuff.
The release date since the fall.
That basically means
anytime from October to early December,
probably closer to October.
just starting
at the beginning of the trailer,
this is Armin talking about racing
Eren and Mikasa to the tree from the child
and they talk about the dreams
of the future that they had as children
and they have a series of flashbacks
to him and Eren as children.
this is then before everything got crazy,
this is them reading a history book.
Eren talking about their dreams
of the future together.
This is Falco.
this is Mikasa using her gear
to get to Eren in his founding Titan form.
This is Reiner.
The Armor Titan. This is peak in her car.
Titan form.
there were a lot of jokes
about this scene, too,
in the manga when they got to it.
Mikasa is wings.
they're literally showing her
having the wings of freedom behind her.
But those are meant to be Falco's
actual wings.
Like Mikasa didn't suddenly sprout wings.
there's been a lot of moments like this
in Attack on Titans history where they
release promos or you see characters
standing in front of the Wings of Freedom,
which are the symbol of the survey corps,
but the symbol meant
to represent their group
being the hope for humanity.
So in this scene, it's
a very obvious metaphor
that Mikasa is the hope for humanity
Because everyone thinks that
Iran has gone crazy
and he's going to destroy all of humanity.
There are a lot of other metaphors
you can draw from
this imagery, too, just based on
what's happening in the context
of what's happening in this moment.
like she's metaphorically an angel meant
to represent freedom, protection, courage.
She's trying to rescue Eren, even though
everybody thinks that he's gone crazy
because of use
what's happening with the Titans
and what's happening with Eren as a curse.
She's trying to free him from that curse.
This is Levi.
There are a couple scenes of him
in the trailer all bandaged up.
This is Jean.
This is Armin. Seeing Amir.
Inside the world of the past.
He's transported into that world
and has a brief conversation with Aaron.
This looks like Bertolt crying.
This is Annie in her female Titan form,
fighting on Aaron's back while he's
transformed into the founding type
with everything going crazy around them.
Like they're in the middle
of this giant battle.
Then all the action drops and it suddenly
switches to this calm Mikasa voice.
And she's telling Aaron
she'll see him again as she's underneath
this tree at the very,
very end of the series.
This is one of the final shots
of the series.
in fact talking about trees, there's
a lot of tree metaphors going on here.
the opening theme song for this
final arc is called Under the Tree,
which is a reference to two different
trees.
the one at the very end of the series
here,
where Mikasa is saying
she'll see Eren again eventually,
like the very final scene
of the actual story.
the other tree being the tree
that ymir originally gained
the power of the founding
titan from thousands of years ago.
the two trees are meant
to look very similar on purpose
just to make the connection back
to the origin of all Titan's more obvious
end it's been the play of the whole idea
of time loops happening in the series,
like the lots of time travel
going on in attack on Titan.
Aaron's comments in the final part,
talking to Armin, where he talks about the
powers of the Titan, allowing him to see
and influence things across time.
he uses that ability to change things
in the past, affecting the future.
Like he can see different timelines
because of the way
the powers of the Titan works. But.
They started to get into this
in previous seasons
when they revealed Eren's ability
to influence events in the past.
that's how he was able to get his father
to kill Frieda, to get the power
of the founding Titan so that he would
eventually be able to get it in the future
and he'd been orchestrating things
like this
throughout the timeline, ultimately
to try and save all of his friends,
even though
most of his friends don't know the truth
of what he's doing, when this is all going
down, most of the trailer just shows you
the giant battle that they have
on the founding Titan trying to stop him
because they still think that he's crazy.
Oh, you're going to kill
all of humanity first.
They were worried about him
killing all the Malians.
They started with that.
But then because the rumbling causes
so much collateral damage,
they're worried about him
destroying all of the human race.
so the idea here at the very end
of this series is that the survey corps,
all of his friends
and all the Malian titans band together
in common cause to try and stop him.
still assuming that his only goal is
to destroy Mali as he's about to reach it.
other thing
that's going on in the background
of some of these trailer scenes, too,
is that the spirit of Amir still exists
inside the world of the past,
has the power to create any new titan.
She wants just one of her regular powers.
we saw a little bit of that
in the previous arcs.
We see her shaping titans out of the sand.
That's
meant to be her creating a new titan.
When someone in the real world activates
their Titan powers, that happens
every single time a titan is activated.
time is meant to move differently
inside the world of the past.
So even though it looks like she's working
super slow fashioning these new titans
in the real world,
the effect is instantaneous.
she can also create other new titans
or previous titans that she wants
and she can turn any lions that she wants
that are alive into titans themselves.
So when all of Eren's friends
in his former enemies
band together to try and stop him,
the spirit of Amir, who now agrees
with Eren, sympathizes with his true
goals, will obey his commands,
and she starts recreating
all the major titans to protect Eren
while the founding Titan is still active.
so she's finger puppet in replicas
of all the original nine titans
against all their friends end
even if they're able to stop those replica
titans, she can just make new ones
any time she wants while this is all going
down she can also, like I said, turn
any living LDN into a regular titan too.
So you wind up with a situation
where all of his friends and former
enemies banded together,
wind up having to face all the nine
titans in addition
to a giant army of regular titans
Then you have someone like Mikasa
who still cares about Eren,
even though everyone else thinks that he's
totally insane now and needs to be killed
Mikasa is trying to free Eren from what
she views as the curse of the Titans
so that they can go live a quite peaceful
life together.
Even though it seems like
Aaron has passed the point of no return.
they referenced this in the poster
for the final episodes in the cabin here
that's meant to be Marcus's cabin,
that she eventually goes to live like that
after the fighting ends
and the threat of the titans are gone.
This is also meant to be Aaron's
tree, the same tree that they show you
in the trailer that grows near the house.
just in general,
The iconography of the tree
is very important
to the end of this series,
as well as the beginning of the series.
it gets into the whole concept of the time
loop and events repeating themselves
over and over again you have Aaron's
final tree growing eventually
and in the distant future.
Another totally different person
thousands of years later,
eventually finds that tree.
And because he died
with the powers of the founding Titan,
when that person falls into the tree,
they'll gain the founding Titan powers,
just like Amir did thousands of years ago.
In the past, Then all these events
play out again in a similar
but slightly different way over and over
and over, like events repeating over time.
this is all happened before.
This will all happen again
arm in and Mikasa eventually kind of learn
the truth about what Eren is doing
like he came up with this idea
that he could save all of his friends
but in order to do that, he had to unite
the entire world in hatred of someone.
And he wanted to be that person.
So he basically fell on a metaphorical
sword, kind of literal, too,
because they tried to kill him
during the series
in order to get everyone to stop
fighting each other and come together.
Eren's true plan was pretty controversial
in the manga.
People were pretty split on whether or not
it was a smart plan or a dumb plan.
but the whole idea here is that
everybody is trying to kill Eren,
but Eren only wants Mikasa
to be able to reach him
so that she can actually secret away
with the powers of the founding Titan
and get rid of them or hide them
because ultimately there's no way for them
to absolutely destroy them.
so if a random person
came along and killed Eren,
they could consume his spinal fluid
and become the next founding
Titan and things would just continue
like the Titans would just continue
part of Aaron's whole plan here is that
he also wants to end the threat
of the titans.
they implied towards the end of the story
though,
that eventually the rest of Aaron's
friends
learned the truth
about what's really going on.
Like they don't end things
with all of his friends
thinking that Aaron went totally insane.
remember even though Aaron thinks that
ultimately he'll be successful
in this grand plan that he's orchestrated
in because that will help him do
it is ultimately someone in the future,
like thousands of years in the future,
will find the powers of the founding
Titan under a similar tree like Amir.
That's what they make it look similar
to her tree from thousands of years ago.
In everything. We'll just repeat.
It'll be just like another time loop,
I'm sure there'll be a ton of questions
about time travel
when this final episode comes out.
if you spotted any other Easter eggs
or references in the trailer
that I didn't talk about in the video,
just write them below in the comments.
Or if you have other questions
about what's happening in the trailer.
like I said, episode probably
going to be out sometime around October,
maybe a little bit later than that.
But there's a bunch of other big stuff
coming up, like the one piece Netflix
live action episodes are coming in August,
Oh, God.
MacGyver.
We haven't sailed together for very long,
but I know we've got each other's backs.
the live action,
Netflix, Avatar The Last Airbender series
is coming next year.
I just did a big trailer video for that.
You can click here to watch that
and click Here for my Secret Invasion
Episode three Video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!